the valley's news leader a new resort is
hoping to help the city rebound from the
covid pandemic
yeah today resorts world las vegas
announced it will open its doors
june 24th joe muller is live near the
strip with more on today's big
announcement joe well guests can now go
online and book reservations for the
much anticipated resorts where i'll take
a live look here this evening at the
the tower here the giant monitors that
can be seen from across the valley share
the message that resorts world is open
for business come june 24th
it's awesome it's very awesome i can't
wait for it to open up visitors and
locals have been watching this bright
red tower become the latest addition to
the las vegas strip
just nice to see this part of town you
know
building up again monday the resort
announced it will open june 24th
guests can now book rooms and other
reservations online a new resort like
this
has proven in the past that it brings
more visitors to the city of las vegas
scott sabila is the president of resorts
world las vegas
from pools to nightclubs he says the
newest strip hotel will be a unique
experience for visitors and locals alike
there hasn't been anything at this level
built in 10 years on the strip
so we took advantage of that we took
advantage of all the advancement and
technology
and how you lay out a property the tower
with a giant monitor is hard to miss
its location on the north end of the
strip means change for the area as well
we know it may not happen overnight but
we know things are shifting this way
we're surrounded by
luxury properties we're surrounded by a
lot of attractions
the mall we love being across street new
convention center
we love that this fair is still going on
sabila says the timing could not be
better
but we're also excited that it could be
perfect timing to help the city
rebound with a property like this so so
we're happy that we can be
part of that and uh we think it's gonna
be a great summer
now back out here live you're taking a
live look at resorts world this evening
where construction is
is going on it's a race against the
clock now we also did check room rates
online earlier today we did find that
rooms are starting in the mid 300s and
they do go up
from there reporting live here near the
strip jim muller 8 news now